quand on est un acteur de la vie
publique française de la vie politique
française c'est bien normal que les
différents les différentes institutions
les groupes politiques les chefs de
partis donnent leur avis ça me semble de
la transparence démocratique après
chacun sait que la responsabilité de
prendre le décret adviendra ce sera le
gouvernement mais le gouvernement aura
partagé les avis avec les forces
politiques de notre pays
pour vous est il encore souhaitable
d'organiser un débat et un vote au
parlement sur la question du second tour
n'a sorti en début de semaine que
c'était plus incertain c'est le premier
ministre qui en décidera cette journée
aujourd'hui est importante puisqu'il
voit l'ensemble des partis politiques
avec leur chef de parti
donc je pense que le le premier ministre
prendra sa décision à la suite de cette
consultation
alors on entends déjà certains se
positionner par exemple le président du
groupe la république en marche au sénat
françois patriat mais aussi par exemple
richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale
ils ne sont pas très favorables à des
élections municipales en juin et
préférer même mars 2021
est ce que vous êtes de leur avis chacun
exprime son avis bon et ses préférences
ce que je sais moi c'est qui hier par
exemple le président de la république
avait organisé une réunion avec 21
maires de france la même réunion qu'il y
a quelques semaines nous avons évoqué ce
sujet et les 21es mère qui était la
représentante août strates toutes
tendances politiques etc ont exprimé
tous la volonté que ça se passe en juin
donc je constate c'est un c'est un
constat que je fais et bien sûr le
président de la république et le premier
ministre prendront leur décision après
avoir écouté l'ensemble des forces
politiques quand on mène campagne pour
vous c'est finalement les difficultés
soulevées par le conseil scientifique
elle des témoins sur la date que sur les
difficultés à faire campagne et
finalement ne sait pas quand est-ce
qu'on pourra retrouver
des réelles bonnes conditions pour
pouvoir faire oui alors c'est vrai que
c'est ce que dit le conseil scientifique
il parle moins de la journée du vote où
les gestes barrières les installations
vont sécuriser le vote que la campagne
en elle-même alors ceci dit il faut
toujours relativiser peut-être je le dis
comme cela vous savez qu'en temps normal
si un deuxième tour avait lieu dans un
timing
si je puis dire classique c'est un
deuxième tour qui se fait en une semaine
puisque s'il n'y avait pas eu report du
deuxième tour vous avez des délices qui
sont déposés le mardi soir et vous avez
jusqu'au vendredi soir pour faire
campagne c'est à dire c'est à dire que
vous avez trois jours pour faire
campagne
bon là il faut aussi imaginer que une
campagne puisse se faire un peu
différemment ou puisse utiliser aussi
les visions conférence était terrassé ce
que nous n'arrêtons pas de faire au
gouvernement depuis le confinement même
encore maintenant puisque nous avons
aidé confinement progressif donc on peut
être aussi créatif est arrivé sûrement
encore à faire campagne de cette manière